in a week where the government set out
its plans to block channel crossings
for the first time we've traced a
journey of one boat and seen the
challenges the authorities faced to stop
smugglers
on the 20th of july this boat brought 13
people to shore
tracing dinghies is extremely hard
but this one had two distinctive
features
its bright orange color and a
registration number on one side
we searched through hundreds of boats
online using reverse image technology
that helped us to find similar pictures
eventually we found an advert for this
boat with the exact same registration
number it was sold 170 miles from where
it landed in dungeness at this boatyard
in holland
so you see if you ever had a big yachty
hands accepted 600 pounds for the dinghy
a few weeks before it crossed the
channel he says the boat was brought by
a couple in their mid-30s believed to be
from belgium but the man spoke a
language that he didn't recognize
it is strange it is very strange if you
see your boat which you showed a couple
of weeks ago
and that you see him with
13 people then you say okay once again
terrible and i'm counting 13 people
which is rather much hans didn't want to
give us the names of the buyers he's
afraid of the repercussions
it is the third time in two years that
boats hands once owned were linked to
immigration crimes
here in 2019 he sold a boat to men he
believes was syrian he helped them
loaded onto a van before they left
without paying despite the cctv released
by dutch police they never caught the
perpetrators it's a lot
less joined up than it was when i was
there but everybody's got their own
their own problems it's their it's
priorities that that's the the issue
what we um
what we need is the europeans to all
work together on this but i don't know
whether that's likely to happen or not
the buyers of the boat that we found in
kent gave an address in antwerp nearly a
two-hour drive from the boatyard which
is another two and a half hours from the
area south of calais where boats often
launch to cross the channel
this is the exact spot in dungeness
where the boat arrived 13 migrants were
on board and they're likely to all have
paid about three thousand pounds each to
be taken across a channel and remember
the boat itself cost less than a
thousand pounds to buy
so smugglers are making a big profit
it is just one story one boat that made
it to britain and so many of these cheap
dinghies that enable illegal crossings
will move around europe untraced before
being left abandoned in dover ali
fortescue sky news